منو يقول وربي ارزقني وتخيل العديد من
الاغنيات المنفرده والالبومات التي لاقت
نجاح واسعا على مستوى الوطن العربي فلسطين
الفنان والملحن العراقي محمود الغياث الذي
بدا مسيرته في عام 2017 في بغداد ورغم
صغار سنه استطاع ان يثبت نفسه في الوسط
الفني يحظى محموده قاعده جماهيريه كبيره
وشارك في العديد من المهرجانات المحليه
العربيه ابرزها مهرجان همسه دولي للفنون
عاما 20 20 في مصر التي حصل فيها على
جائزه الابداع عن اغنيه الشهيره ربي
ارزقني كما تعاون فنيا مع الفنانات رحمه
رياض واصاله والشمس الكويتيه هو بالاضافه
الى صوته العذب ملحن متنوعه الكلمه
[موسيقى]
بانك اصغر فنان يلحن ويغني ولو هذه
الجماهير الكبير على مواقع التواصل وبين
الجمهور في الحفلات المباشره حديثنا اكثر
عن محمود
الحمد لله مثل ما قلت انه بديت ب 2017 همم
بدايه الاستديو صغير
بغداد انا واصدقائي بعدين اتطور الموضوع
كبر اشتغل شركات همم ناجحه يعني داخل
العراق
وبغيت هاي الشركات ضمن اجتهادي اكيد
والحمد لله والشكر انه توفقنا وصلنا لهذه
المنطقه اللي هي لابد انه لازم يكون بعده
وراءها تكمله تكون قد حسن ظن الجميع
في 2017 وكان لك اغاني ناجحه لكن اشتهرت
بسرعه البرق بعد ما غنيت ربي ارزقني
هالاغنيه الحمد لله الاغنيه لغتنا نجاح
كلش حلو بالنسبه الي انا فنان بعد من همم
ثلاث سنوات في السنه الثالثه صار عندي هذا
النجاح طبعا هو بالبدايه توفيق من رب
العالمين
كنا نشتغل به بس انا حسيت هذه الاغنيه
اكثر اغنيه من بين البوم اللي طرحتها بسنه
2019 اللي هو كان البوم مليون واحد اكثر
اغنيه دخلت للعوائل والقلوب والناس وكانت
سهله بالنسبه للاستماع يعني من كل فئات
العمريه
رحمه رياض اصيل هميم كل فنانين احبهم شو
السر الاغنيه العراقيه ليش اكتسحت الساحه
انه هي تكون اغنيه شامله همم خصوصا الكلام
العراقي كلام يوصل للقلب بسرعه كلام همم
كل المنطقه العربيه تفتهمه احنا بالاجمع
عنه احنا دائما نتفق على انه اللغه
المصريه هي اشهر لغه
بالوطن العربي او اشهر لهجه
عربيه
بالوطن العربي لكن الاغنيه العراقيه همم
صارت متربعه على عرش الاغاني العربيه
بالفتره الاخيره لانه الكلام
والشعر العراقي همم باوزان مفتوحه
وبمعاني حلوه ودام الاغنيه العراقيه طوها
انطباع انه هي حزينه دائما بس همم الحمد
لله كل ملحنينه وكل شعراءنا شطار يجددون
ما بين فتره وفتره حتى يطرحون الاعمال
دائما يشوفوها الغزليه اللي هي اخر فتره
اكتسحت الساحه تحياتي لهم وان شاء الله
الله يوفقهم ويوفقنا عرب حتى نوصل الاغنيه
العربيه للعالميه ان شاء الله
ربي رزق نفاد عشق بس هو الابالي صار النفس
مالي ما غيره يحلالي
خلاني اطير بلا جناح يمه ايش حلو عطره
دللني كل عمره كلي تحت امرك اللي تحت امرك
وانا القى مثلك بالعمر يا اجمل ستور فنانه
في الحب والغزل بس
[موسيقى]